I know you have six kids
um seven actually I just had a baby
Robert De Niro revealing he's a dad
again and yes this is the seventh child
for the 79 year old actor anybody can
relate to it De Niro shared the happy
news with E.T Canada a rep for the star
confirming the little one's arrival on
Tuesday I know
I know you kids
um seven actually I just had a baby the
major life update comes as De Niro
promotes his latest comedy about my
father
Springer no I don't think so where he
plays you guessed it
okay it's called love and affection then
unlike you when you met me at the
delivery room you chose to shake my
hands what else was I supposed to do we
just met I don't think that I'm a cool
father I'm okay you know my kids
disagree with me at times and they're
respectful my daughter is in 11 she's
gives me a grief sometimes I adore her
of course the legendary actor has played
a dad on screen many times
I have nipples Greg could you milk me he
famously played Ben Stiller's uh quirky
father-in-law in the Meet the Parents
trilogy
you just blew it what he also starred as
Leonardo DiCaprio's Stern dad in This
Boy's Life and I had a talk with Jack on
the way up here and he
he wants to be a better boy what was it
like working with Robert De Niro he was
just like a regular normal guy to me he
knew that I really respected him as an
actor and stuff so it would have been
like hell for me to have her opportunity
you know
giving me a face every time and two of
his adult children 51 year old Drina and
27 year old Julian have followed dad's
footsteps into acting as long as you
work diligently hard you try your best
it'll work in your favor tenfold De Niro
opened up to E.T in 2002 about the
advice he shared with his kids as they
enter Show Business the downside is if
you don't or give them any excuse to say
that you're doing it just you know
you're not doing as well as you should
or you're slacking off or you're doing
it like this because you you're the
child of so-and-so it'll go tenfold in
the negative so you really always have
to do the right thing to keep going as
for what's next for De Niro well 30
years later he's reuniting with Leo in
Martin scorsese's next movie Killers of
the flower Moon Jesse plemons who's also
in the flick told E.T working with De
Niro means you gotta come prepared you
Mr Robert De Niro what's it like working
with a legend like that it definitely
makes you feel like you you gotta you
gotta bring it you know I have worked
with them a few times you know we had
one scene and killers of the flower Moon
that was just like I could have retired
after after that and Leo and I have we
worked together when he was a teenager a
little kid but now he's grown up we
always wanted to do something together
so this is it it's a great movie
plus two other movies later this year
and he's already shot another film
hitting theaters in 2024 clearly a busy
actor and a busy dad seven actually
foreign